okay for the daily wire it says a um
luden county virginia
and eventually i'll figure out how to
actually pronounce lao is it loud i
think it's loudon okay
lewden lewton county virginia um a
loudoun county virginia elementary
school teacher who was placed on
administrative leave in may for refusing
to affirm transgender identity children
was reinstated by a judge on tuesday
byron tanner cross who teaches physical
education at leesburg elementary school
secured a temporary injunction
from judge james plowman in his lawsuit
against
loudoun county public schools according
to an announcement from
alliance defending freedom which
defended him
adf tweeted quote tanner cross a
virginia elementary school teacher and
adf client who was suspended for raising
concerns to the board
about proposed gender policy has won a
temporary injunction
and the judge has ordered his
reinstatement a massive victory
for freedom of speech i would only
offer one correction it's not just a
victory for freedom of speech it's a
victory for
for truth for science for sanity all
those things that i said we should be
conserving it's a victory for that
um local wtop
reporter neil oginski augenstein
reported that
plowman found the school system's
suspension was unconstitutional
and its handling of the situation was
vindictive yeah you think
the school argued that it suspended
cross not for his beliefs but because of
the disruption he allegedly caused
but plowman said there was simply an
absence of evidence that any disruption
to school operations
took place and yeah if it does just
disrupt school operations
it's because you have decided to operate
the school
around this anti-science anti-truth
totally insane gender theory thing
if if if a teacher simply affirming
that boys are boys and girls or girls
disrupts operation
that tells me something about the way
that the school's being operated
but now he's being reinstated so i
wanted to highlight that story as a nice
little contrast
okay in one case you have a guy he
didn't do anything wrong
grovels and apologizes loses his job
loses everything loses respect loses
social acceptance loses everything he
wants oh
he he gives up his dignity and uh and in
exchange gets
nothing in return the very next story
you have someone
who also did nothing wrong faced
consequences for it
rather than apologizing rather than
coming out and saying oh gee
you know come to think of it i guess
yeah i guess sometimes boys are girls
silly me i'm so sorry for my transphobia
rather than doing that which is what
most people do
we have this teacher who's fighting back
he's saying hell no
this is not going to happen i'll take
you to court
and for now he's he's winning
and even if he doesn't ultimately win i
mean even if ultimately he gets uh
he loses the job with all said and done
and all the in
and you know this has made its way
through all the courts and everything
still you know he would have lost his
job anyway
but now he retains his dignity and he's
fighting for truth and he's doing the
right thing
and he's sending a message that you know
what not everybody is going to slink
away quietly
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content